hello everybody my name is Mark Blair
why do I even bother doing an intro for
these things I've got funny videos
supposedly I've got funny videos now
it's not guaranteed that they're gonna
be funny but what is guaranteed is if
any of you laugh I'm gonna come over to
your house and I'm gonna find you and
I'm gonna punch you in the gonads so
don't laugh and that goes for myself I
will punch myself in the gonads if I
laugh at this one so there's that
promise wink
okay whatever I'm ready let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wow I mean well uh wait hang on I
forgot what I was doing here I forgot
what I was doing everybody hold on that
didn't count
that was nothing I forgot Wow
Wow that's good moves no you can't bring
animals in here and expect me to laugh
every time that's not how this works
don't do it whatever you're doing don't
nope
[Music]
sadly one oh no I hope that wasn't
permanent saying that before you have
the [ __ ] wheel yeah jr. what does the
will have to do with the brake [ __ ]
calm down mom calm down what what kind
of stupid idea what in the world stupid
idea is that what kind of dumb what are
they doing I'm sorry my brain just took
a second to process what I just saw
there hang on is that that one of those
we would call them buggies is that that
a horse is that am I saying this right
I'm ascared
I'm a skier buggy horse and all right I
saw it yeah I did
Oh No
No why why why no no no no no that's the
cutest thing I've ever seen in my life
that is so cute
that's so cute that's so cute that's so
cute
that's so cute oh
that's amazing hope he's okay no no no
like this no like this please not like
this that's cute that's cute that's cute
this badge is better a lot of cute stuff
a lot of cute but it's it's gonna catch
me off guard cuz I'm all smiley now and
the next thing I know I'm gonna laugh or
the next thing I see that's ingenious
that's really smart
the beauty of human ingenuity is
beautiful
what mmm I sing what am I seeing
it's a good day
[Laughter]
oh oh okay I'm sorry I'm sorry
oh god it's it's so slow I don't I don't
know why that made me laugh is so hard
it's so slow okay move it okay goodbye
[Laughter]
Oh God I'm gonna have an aneurysm I'm
gonna have an injury no okay all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
this person trusted you you black belt
oh well actually no that's his killer
instinct he's just so used to going for
the murder that he can't help it
I think III think I'd died actually I'm
pretty sure that I'm not alive anymore
I'm in a different plane of existence at
this moment so I um yeah I I will yeah
anyway so this has been the try not to
laugh challenge um okay so I'm old for
like what 20 something I'm over 20 now
so one of these days one of these days
I'll get him I'll get him I'll get him
one of these days I'll show these videos
who's boss
I'll show who I'll show these videos
who's boss one day but thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
got other funny videos you want me to
watch get it um to me somehow watch the
other try not to laugh so I'll put them
in the description hit subscribe for
more videos
ring that bell if you want to be
notified when my uploads are leave a
like if you enjoyed it it's sign up for
my newsletter go - markiplier comm cloak
brand and just thank you everybody so
much for watching take care of
yourselves and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye